hey i'm trinidad james' and i'm spencer
shapiro today we're here talking about
some of the top eyewear trends that you
see on celebrities these days me and
Spencer we met through another mutual
ideal and by the name of Chris smokes
Chris smokes is from Detroit Spencer is
also from Detroit I specialize in
vintage Cartier but I also have a lot of
other brands like Gucci Versace limited
edition Louboutin just in general all
types of vintage eyewear from 70s until
now a lot of these frames you can't find
in stores it's kind of like buying a
classic Rolex or you know old school
chevy things like that so that's where I
come into play finding those pieces that
people want but they can't get glasses
for me and shades for me they all have
different meanings different points in
my life different parts of success
different money it means a lot of
different things like these six one six
if I'm not mistaken cause all these are
the first glasses I ever wore bought all
go everything video these are like the
first yea these glass is probably only
go for probably about four hundred five
hundred dollars but there's no value on
my furnace like my first chain he's my
first shades that ever like got me into
the game of glasses
one trend you see a lot these days are
like thick goggle like frames like big
frames they said fur so he said rocky
okie Stanfield and it's and paw of
course the og Spike Lee all wearing big
frames and you see I'm definitely a fan
of the big frames so I kinda like it
eases like street wear glasses
I don't really call them cargo like the
orange wheels are like new new version
Versace that's like the new stage of
Versace so it's cute it's alright you
know I'm saying it's like plastic like
just new plastic glasses like you wear
them as quick fashion I would have I
don't really look at these is iconic
they're more quick fashion to me certain
ones are iconic like if you go to a
saffron key you're not finding those no
worth that particular colors are like I
tell you certain colors are very hard to
find those glasses are awesome of course
it's the red of that verb of that blue a
problem complete problem
lucky Stanfield those glasses that
particular style a particular shape so
many brands make that shape from YSL all
the way to infinity la the end of the
pack same thing those glasses covered a
million different colors sometimes you
just want to walk in to Foot Locker you
know regular sneaker boutique just grab
something off the shelf that's you know
affordable fun you don't always have to
be wearing some crazy shoe out of flight
club that's 10k some wild collector's
edition so you know it's good to mix it
up and have all different price range in
your new collection like street wear for
classes find the colors to match your
outfit I won't have a dark lens you
can't see my eyes I'm having a time I
had a good time ago I like it well as
fashion continues you look at her
personally little Nozick's it was
completely there you know he's the new
hottest thing on earth by the earth
right now and he's rocking the Cullens
you looking at the year 2000 kind of
come back around like Fifth Element
how would every know where those wild
funky colors people are wearing those
are not scared of it
pink is fine for a man to wear and women
don't just have to wear pink you know
you can wear whatever color you want and
it's a beautiful time because people are
expressing themselves through our
through color
and it's so great through people
identifying through color you get to see
artists like Deb Hines Matthew
McConaughey little Nozick's where color
frames that is totally fine totally
masculine nothing wrong there it's a
different time they might disappear it I
would have her in a few years but right
now they're today but one example would
be like Luca over here you know from the
looks of it he's just wearing some
really simple aviators if that was just
a clear clear tan or just black you know
maybe you just walk by and wouldn't even
in second you know think of it twice but
that red it really makes it special and
just it elevates the frame really
elevates his whole look it's all about
having that variety and there's the
right tents for the right moment what I
like to do I like to cut extra sets of
lenses for my personal frames some days
I might feel like wearing blue some days
I might want clear you know other days I
just want to go all black fin and out
depends on your mood your outfit there's
a lot of things you gotta match at you
well if you look at those pictures that
Elton John yeah and he has orange lenses
blue lenses like color and lens has
always been a way for you to show who
you are you know you also see the world
a little bit differently you know is
that like oh you see clear and everybody
else in color the color that people see
in you is the same colors you see in the
world you know and Blues have a
different feel Reds have a different
feel all these different colors and
tints have a different feeling different
outlook on world when you look through
the lens
aviators have been kind of getting more
of a modern update I've seen a lot of
brands like Dior kind of removing the
bridge and then they just keep the bar
across the top what that does for the
face it kind of long gates the nose and
gives you kind of different feel
continuing with what you're saying about
offset and no bridge there it's really
interesting I never paid attention to it
does define more of your nose interests
also with these updated aviators they're
all dark compared to the Aviators we
looked at before they had like a color
lens and let you in these aviators do
not letting you it these are like cop
aviators Top Gun Tom Cruise type you
know aviators wears like a man I'm cool
I'm serious and I might not want to be
something spoken to so it's really
interesting to see the difference in
what a dark tint can do to a v8 or any
pair of glasses compared to color tint
or a transitional tip I love it I mean I
can never go against a it has a modern
look but it still goes back to his
classic roots so yeah I approve of that
for sure but I'm just very selective
with aviators it's not my cup of tea but
once in a while somebody will make a pan
of it oh wow is it good we're calling
this the matrix look you know it gives
you that Keanu Reeves neo feel and it's
a serious look it's small you know it's
dark and usually it gives you that look
we're not necessarily [ __ ] but more
of leave him alone leave her low really
just changes the whole look just an
aggressive badass look and its really
its futuristic but it also has ties back
to late 90s early 2000s you can see on
the weekend he has a little of the
jacket you can see that Hans has a
leather jacket if you look at Swizz
Beatz has a leather jacket certain
eyewear brings out a certain energy in
you it's just if you can't help it it's
a science to this I know it might seem
cliche but these are three different
pictures of three different artists
three different type of learners they
don't talk to each other they don't hang
with each other
how would everybody all have a leather
jacket with these matrix style glasses
why is that because they feel like a
badass once you find the i-word it looks
good on your face it's just
of your body thanks like put on the mass
if I take these off put these off and
we'll talk different if I take these off
put those off over talk different
because it's a different person talking
to and if you look at it your same
glasses even if not the same they're
very similar sort calling the same right
look at the demeanor same demeanor
serious you know I'm saying and these
could be the nicest guys ever but those
glass when you put them on they really
they erase your comfort zone they erase
you looking nice
like there's just it's something real
serious about it I appreciate it when
you see home you know people wearing icy
glasses not every pair is necessarily
real diamond some are rhinestones Roth
ski crystals you know little Jarvis
that's cool too it's all about you look
now you've seen a lot of big clunky
glasses with crazy rhinestones I mean I
think adafak has all these saline
glasses in that picture actually these
are not real diamond you know these
costume Jerry you know it looks good
and it's not like quavo or Lil Wayne or
Anza or has the bat can't afford to wear
real diamond glasses it's just not that
serious
every time oh it's not that serious you
know hey this is a more beautiful thing
of it is that ten years ago or early
two-thousands you might never see men
wearing but thousand big glasses like
that they were known to be feminine so
to see the times change and men finding
the expression through these different
shapes of glasses and stones and
bedazzle this without that it's a better
time there is a pair of glasses for
everyone you just gotta get your mind
open to wanted to try different things
not being pigeon-holed to what you think
doesn't work for you
[Music]
ground frames I really I've really
become a big trend over the years you
can see a lot of people like Big Sean
for example he's wearing the classic
green cabriolets I got my Salah leave
incredible actor it's really good to see
round glasses on a person like himself
because well Solly is not an old man not
the youngest man
so to see his style come through on
screen on camera and even with pictures
like this it's really dope those round
glasses look good over reading glasses
as club glasses is always been a thing
you know at the end of the day we found
some glasses that make you look cute
where does last that's what I would tell
you it's always been a style even from
people wearing glasses wouldn't pop out
the lens and just be clear everybody's
not blessed to have 20/20 vision so a
lot of us need glasses so some people
cheated and put on the glasses to you
know give them the feel of looking glass
sometimes people believe that glasses
make them smarter Julian kelvins and Tom
Ford's thugs always doing it right with
the eyewear no matter what and that's
another guy who's not afraid to push
boundaries with fashion in general I'm
not really into the Brooklyn Beckham
he's an adult now but I'm not those
worked for him but I wouldn't rock those
I wouldn't rock the quest low either but
they look good on you you know you
finally find that shape that works for
your face is good these are the Chanel
furrows for us your nails like we want
to word it but they're based off of the
glasses that take off as on the original
Chanel Paris ones - I definitely want it
back in the day and I still don't have
four rails one of the first people I
ever seen wearing the original Chanel
Paris I was fun glasses he made a man
white and black in the beginning but now
with this particular style you have a
green black red blue yellow the original
ones you can't find in stores adults
you'd have to go through you know
vintage eyewear dealer define them those
have been rising in price like crazy
sometimes up to as high as 2 K the
Chanel thrill was around 750 in stores
but same thing those sold out within
days and now they're reselling - wait
are you
one style that is kind of been all over
and I've had to pay attention to it
because I don't have probably any
glasses like it is the extra skinning
look a prime and perfect example of it
is little nas X again to me that's kind
of like a 90s look like a real 90s mary
j blige that's a palooka which I
appreciate but I don't rock because I
have a big face and big eyes so it
doesn't work for me look some some of
those guys but for me I could never pull
it off this trend is a face I mean
everything is up not being a phase but
improve me to prove you're different
prove it prove it but this is the face I
mean the reason why I say is a phase is
because I personally feel people who
like wearing glasses that cover their
eyes more than glasses that show so much
of that tiny glasses look great on who
they look great on but it's not very
conventional so everyone looking at this
segment it's very important for you to
understand the size of your face
understand what glasses actually fits
you you know a lot of people get
frustrating a lot of people feel that oh
glass is not for me I don't have a face
for glasses but you definitely have a
face for glasses like there's a pair of
glasses for every face just like there's
a song for every person in order to
understand what glasses you need to wear
I think that Spencer you could help us
out like a fun fact that I didn't know
he had to help me out of how to identify
what size these glasses are what size
fit your face every frame has a unique
set of numbers that can help you
identify the size so for example this is
a cardioid mom Mason the numbers for the
lens and the bridge would be on the
inside right here so this for example is
of 56:19 so that's 56 across here in
millimeters 19 millimeters across the
bridge on the inside it's a 135 so
that's the arm length so some are longer
some are shorter depending on all how
your ears are for example on a wire
frame wire or plastic frame that can be
extended and bent out by your optician
so anywhere around here can be adjusted
they are put in a special machine and
heat it up
it usually takes five minutes at most
all my glasses speak to me there's like
almost a personal way and the spiritual
way because I just they make me feel so
good or whatever like allows me to bring
out different emotions those reason when
I feel bougie and I feel like I don't
want ya you put your hater blockers I'm
gonna put on these Celine so you can get
out my face and I don't even see I'm
gonna feel you know but energy is
different you know so I like all the
shades you know even when I put on these
Stella McCartney's which is a newer pair
for me I look at these like when I put
these on you're like oh who is that you
know I'm saying maybe I want attention
[Music]